bayon rejoint à luchon jean marc aras
pour la séquence escapade de ce vendredi
matin la liaison était habillé en pensez
bien au pardon au père du chat mais je
suis désolé
merci beaucoup mais je vais dire assez
bien que c'est
bon alors je merci olivier c'est
agréable
je suis un adversaire retrouvé dans le
rhin dans une petite boutique du 3e
arrondissement
l'impôt tissu belles étoffes merci cet
agrément mais non mais je vais prendre
un mouchoir je vais là mais si vous êtes
témoin regardez-moi sa statue ça fait
animateurs ça fait animateur py ces
seniors c c'est glacé en plus et vous ne
voyez pas pour l'instant mais à
l'intérieur ça cool
ça des goules et luchon jean marc aras
j'essaie de me changer allô bonjour
tu fous